So I'm going to make a prediction.
The chances of this video going viral is this
big.
Here's why.
Because no one cares to talk about customer
complaints.
But I promise you, I want to challenge you
to listen to this whole thing because it will
save you a lot of sleepless nights, it will
make you a lot of money, it will save you
a lot of money and it will just create a culture
for your company.
So let's get right into it.
Complaints are a part of business.
When you decide to become a business owner,
you are putting yourself out there for customers
to say you are not as good as XYZ and it is
our job to hear them out and get better because
this is free counsel that people are giving
you.
Just think about it.
There's companies that do focus groups that
pay $75 per participant to just show up and
complain about your product and you're getting
all these things for free.
That's one of the things I want you to be
keeping in mind.
Now let's talk about how I look at complaints.
There are five different types of complainers
when it comes down to your business and no
matter what you do, there's five different
types of people that complain about what you
do.
The number one type of complainer is the valid
complaint.
This is the person that's right.
You did something wrong.
Your company didn't do the right thing.
The procedures, the offers, anything that
happened, they're absolutely right with what
took place.
And I'm going to explain you how to handle
that.
But the first one is the valid complainers.
Whatever complaint that was made, you have
to figure out how to improve that.
The pessimist.
This is the person that no matter where you
go with them, nothing can ever make them happy.
Nothing can make them happy.
So you can do anything and everything for
them, they will never be happy with what you
do for them.
This is the customer you have as well.
The third type of customer is the one that
they like your product, they disagree with
your beliefs.
For instance, hypothetically, imagine the
CEO of Starbucks gets up and he says, "I believe
that healthcare should be free for everybody."
And there's someone that goes to Starbucks
and loves the coffee, but they absolutely
disagree politically with what Howard Schultz
believes when it comes down to national healthcare.
For example, imagine if you are the CEO of
Wal-Mart, and you believe in capitalism, and
they always go to Wal-Mart and shop, but they
HATE what the company stands for and they
support certain people politically or a team
or whatever it is, so they have a vendetta
toward you.
I'll give you a story.
One time with a rant complainer that happened
with me.
This was six and a half years ago, we had
just started our firm, and I will never forget
what happened with this story here because
I remember I got this, all of a sudden, this
person started posting all over our Facebook,
Twitter, you know, every single website that
we had, they were just complaining, complaining,
complaining, this company sucks, this CEO's
horrible, bop, bop, bop, bop, all this stuff.
So finally, I called Mario, and I said, "Mario,
I need to get that guy's number.
I'm going to call him."
So I get his number.
I call him up, at night.
I'll never forget it.
It's 10:00 at night.
It's 8:00 his time, I'm on the phone with
him.
I said, "Hey, this is Patrick Bet-David, giving
you a, The CEO of PHP.
I just wanted to call you.
It seems you're extremely upset.
I wanted to call you instead of having someone
else call you.
Can you tell me what you're not happy about?"
And we went on a 45-minute conversation.
Do you want to know what this conversation
was over?
Let me tell you what this conversation was
over.
This conversation was over the fact that he
belonged to the biggest communistic organization
in America and he's a proud believer and follower
of Karl Marx, a book called Communist Manifesto.
And he found out that I believe in capitalism
and I followed the teaching of Milton Freedman,
and he HATES capitalism.
He hates capitalism!
So I'll never forget the conversation that
we had together and this became a friendly
conversation.
So I said, "Why do you hate capitalism?"
And he said, "I hate capitalism because all
they care about is they put the people to
work."
And I said, okay, let's take capitalism out.
Where do you work at right now?
He said, "I know where you're going with this."
Where do you work at?
He said, "I work at PF Changs."
I said, "What happens if PF Changs goes out
of business?"
He said, I'll go work for another company.
I don't care about PF Changs."
I said, "You're going to go work for another
capitalist.
What if that capitalist goes out of business?"
I'm going to go get another job, because I
will always be needed.
I said, "Without the capitalists, you don't
have a job.
So we had this friendly debate.
Fast forward six years later, literally nine
months ago, this guy sends me a message saying,
you don't remember me.
Of course I remember him.
I have a pretty decent memory.
You won't remember me, but we debated six
years ago when I was a communist and I just
want you to know I follow every single Valuetainment
video, and I believe in capitalism.
Things have changed.
I'm 29 years old.
Back then I was 23 years old.
I said, okay, no problem.
But I had to figure out that that person had
no problem with our product.
They had a problem with the belief system
and although I can't change that, I heard
him out, we fixed it, we moved on from there.
The fourth type of complainers that you have
that's become a very big business is an actual
enemy.
So what I mean by an enemy or a competitor,
this has become a very, very big business.
Let me explain.
So here's a big gorilla, big guy, big company
that's been doing a business and you're planning
on coming and taking a percentage of their
business away from them, right?
You're an enemy.
You're a threat.
They don't like you.
You need to go out of business ASAP.
And so we started a company, and we're trying
to take distribution away from some folks.
When I say distribution, the amount of life
insurance that's being written, so we want
to start writing this business.
That didn't make a lot of people happy.
That ticked off a lot of people.
So all of a sudden, we got a floodgate, we
got flooded with negative complaints online.
And you could tell, there was a lot of things
being said that's inaccurate with details,
where you know somebody else was doing it
and eventually we went and investigated it
and we realized what's going on with that.
And there's nothing we could do about it.
Here's why there's nothing we could do about
it.
Because companies like Yelp, as much as I
use Yelp as a customer to go figure out what
restaurants are out there and which restaurant
to choose around the world, I don't like what
Yelp does to small business owners.
I'll tell you exactly what Yelp does to small
business owners.
yelp will come up to you and they'll say,
"If you advertise $6,000 a month, $5,000 a
month, we will give you a shot at putting
out more positive reviews and all this other
stuff.
When they went public, they changed their
script.
I'll never forget it because I spoke to one
of their reps.
He said, Patrick, yes, we used to do that.
But we don't do that anymore because now we're
public and we have so many different people
that have said that we did that and now we
have to answer to that so all this stuff he
started telling me.
So I said the reality part of it is after
some employees left Yelp, they started telling
us that this is what they're doing and that's
a business nowadays.
They take small businesses that are frightened
to go out of business and through fear, because
of a small restaurant being a three-star people
will not go.
Their business drops by 20%, they ask you
for $6000 a month.
So it's a legal, online Mafia type of thing
if you want to call it like back in the days,
you know how people would come and say, hey,
you got to pay me more taxes if you want to
do business.
It's something like that going on.
You got to figure out a way to work around
that.
The reason you have to figure out a way to
work around that is because eventually when
you earn saint status, none of that stuff
matters.
And saint status takes about a decade, five
years to ten years depending on the business
that you have to earn.
And once you earn saint status, this means
when your positive experiences are just crushing
the negative comments that no one even pays
attention to the negative comments any more.
You don't even think about Apple's negative
comments.
You know how many negative comments Apple
gets.
People still go to Apple.
You don't even care about Wal-Mart's negative
complaints any more.
You know how many people work at Wal-Mart.
2.3 million people, 1.4 million in America.
I just got the update because last week I
said 1.5 million, 2.2, it's 1.4 million in
America, 2.3 million around the world, 900,000
people around the world work for Wal-Mart,
even though they have more complaints than
almost any other company in the world, they
also happen to be the biggest company in the
world, top three biggest companies in the
world depending on the time.
Then the fifth one is the final one is the
trolls.
Nowadays there's trolls.
Trolls has become a new thing, because this
is a way for someone to get fame.
This is a way for someone to say oh my gosh,
I'm going to go mess with this company because
I may get publicity and I may get picked up.
So it's become a business.
There's actually, you can go to sites that
tell you how to be a professional troller.
It's hilarious.
We get some trolls sometimes on Valuetainment.
I had this one guy that trolled me one time.
I won't tell you what I told him, but he trolled
me.
Paul is already laughing back there because,
so this guy comes in, he starts trolling Valuetainment.
And then I go to his Facebook page, and on
his Facebook Page, the most recent post he
posted, he said, "I'm in the mood to go troll
some bigger brands."
This is on his Facebook Page!
So I took a screenshot and I said, "Let's
have some fun."
Because if you want to have fun, I don't mind
it.
Crap talking games.
I went at him pretty hard.
He deleted his comment and came back.
We had a fun time with it.
But trolls, I appreciate trolls because at
least they're trying to become celebrities.
So don't take trolls too seriously.
They're actually fun to be dealing with.
So you have those five types of complainers.
Now let's talk about your business and how
to handle these complaints.
First of all, depending on the type of a business
you run, your volume of sales that come in
will dictate how many opportunities there
are for people to complain with your product,
meaning if your volume of sales is high, there's
more likelihood of you having complaints.
So for example, if I take 1,000 shots in a
basketball game, vs. another guy that comes
in and only gets one shot in a basketball
game, who has the higher likelihood of shooting
an air ball?
The guy that shoots 1,000 shots, or the guy
that shoots one shot? 1,000 shots is going
to get some air balls.
And air balls could be complaints, it could
be a misplay, it could be something that happened
that you have to address.
So you've got to understand the business you've
chosen to be a part of.
And if it's high volume, you're going to get
more complaints.
Low volume, fewer complaints, and so it's
simply on the way you do your business.
So now how you handle complains when you get
them.
It's very simple.
#1: the most important thing before I tell
you how to respond is the following.
Speed is your game.
Speed.
The complaint happens Tuesday.
If you get back to them by Friday, it's already
too late.
Complaint happens at Tuesday, at 3:00 in the
afternoon, if you have a system where you
get back to them within a day, that's better
than Friday.
But if you have a way to get back to them
immediately, because you get prompted with
a notification that somebody's not happy,
you get back to them within an hour, that
means it matters to them.
So speed is your number one game of handling
complaints.
#2 when it comes down to handling complaints
is avoiding conflict.
If you avoid conflict, I guarantee you, you
will constantly be getting complaints.
So let me tell you what type of brands I am
extremely suspicious of.
I remember one time I sat down with a guy
and he said, "I turned off all my comments
on YouTube."
I said, "Why?" he said, "Well, you know YouTube
has a way for you to hide your number of subscribers
and hide your number of comments because no
one will know how many subscribers you have
so you can kind of make it up and say how
many you have, and no one will say the bad
things people are saying about you."
I said, "First of all, I want to hear the
negative comments because I want to figure
out a way for sound is not good.
You know how many things we've improved on
our brand because of how many Valuetainers
have told us the sound only comes from one
ear.
Paul, how many times have you gotten a message
where [Paul: Too many!].
Too many times, so Paul over here, he's got
to figure that part out.
Or hey, you guys spelled Entrepreneur wrong.
We chose this word called entrepreneur and
every time entre pre pre neur, pre neur, Paul,
pre neur, right?
So, hey, you misspelled entrepreneur.
Great.
We want to hear this stuff.
Brands that are too concerned about hiding
all the negative comments, I'm very suspicious
about.
What are you hiding?
Who cares about negative comments?
No one's perfect.
See, we don't have a standard of perfection.
I want to hear about it.
Because I want to see what my audience is
going to say about it so we can be held accountable
and we can improve.
So, don't avoid conflict.#3, you can't win
them all.
That's for sure.
You cannot win them all.
And then four, I like the phones.
A lot of times people like to handle complaints
with, what do you call it, just an email and
respond.
And that's great, that's a way you can do
it.
But I love phones.
I can't tell you how many issues I've resolved
in my life by simply picking up the phone
and just calling and saying, what is the problem
that we have going on here?
Just last week I got an email from a CEO of
a $40 billion company and there was a very
strange email.
So I responded back and I said, "hey, this
is a strange email you sent me.
How about we get on a phone to clear this
thing up."
He said, "You know what?
You're right.
Let's get on a call together."
We got on a call together and things got cleared
up because what he thought happened was somebody
said to him that was absolutely inaccurate.
We got clarity.
He went and investigated.
He said, you're right.
This is exactly what happened.
Great.
We moved on.
I like handling issues immediately with a
phone call.
Now let me tell you about how to respond.
When you get on the phone, or you send an
email, or you respond, whatever it is, number
one, `thank them for taking time out of their
schedule to critique your product, your company,
you, thank them.
The most valuable asset anybody has is time
and if they took time to write you, and give
you feedback, let me tell you, that is more
valuable than other people that are not willing
to do that because you don't matter to them
that much.
it matters to them.
I was at PF Changs the other day.
I've been a customer of PF Changs, I've probably
been to PF Changs 400 times in my life.
One of the reasons is because when I was at
Woodland Hills, PF Changs was right across,
and then here, I got a waiter, a guy named
Brian in Dallas I really like when I see him
in Vegas, and when I'm in Dallas, I got a
waiter I really like.
I went to PF Changs the other day, yesterday,
and I had a bit of a meltdown.
I was there with my wife and kids.
When I say meltdown, I know it.
So when we sat down, it took 21 minutes before
water touched our table.
It took 48 minutes before appetizer touched
our table, okay?
I called the manager and I saw the manager
talking to another person, and they looked
at us and they still didn't come to talk to
us.
They're not that busy.
This was 1:00, 1:30 on Sunday, traffic was
already gone.
Then our waitress here kept avoiding us, and
they kept going to other people because she
was handling this bill and she kept saying,
"I'll come back, I'll come back."
Nine minutes from the moment she said that,
she didn't come back, right?
Now let me tell you this here.
I am a valid complainer to PF Changs because
I want to come back to PF Changs.
And I want them to resolve this because I
love service.
Makes sense.
So I took the time to give feedback.
Now what the manager does with that is on
them.
I may not go back on Sunday because I know
the manager's going to be there on Sundays.
So number one is thank them.
# 2 is speak like a human being.
Have you ever done customer service with people
where they speak to you and they're too scripted?
Well, thank you for the complaint that you
have here, and I just want you to know that
it means a lot to us and all this stuff.
Listen.
Hey, John, I'm sorry, man.
I'm sorry about this experience.
Tell me about what happened.
Can you tell me a little bit more?
I really want to hear you out.
Yes, here's.
. . speak to them like a human being.
What happened?
This is what took place.
#3, apologize for the experience.
Acknowledge, be honest, and acknowledge, hey,
we messed up here.
It sounds like we messed up.
Do you mind if I investigate a little bit
more and get back to you?
Sure.
Hey, it's sounds like we're at fault here
for what we did.
And I'm not happy about that.
Let me see what we can do about it.
Yes.
Oh my gosh, I'm so sorry that you experienced
this.
Okay, So acknowledge it.
#5 remain calm.
I can tell you, many experience that I haven't
remained calm, that sometimes and by the way,
almost every case that I didn't remain calm,
didn't work in my favor.
I just want you to know this.
Almost every single case that I didn't remain
calm hasn't worked in my favor.
And I've done that many times, and I had to
learn to overcome that.
Now sometimes it may be the fact that I don't
want that business any more.
And to me, it's a way to say, I don't want
to do business with this person any more.
But it's still not an excuse to not handle
people well because if you treat somebody
good, they tell three people.
If you treat somebody bad, they tell 11 people.
People like to spread bad experiences more
than they like to spread good experiences.
It is what it is.
This is why media and CNN and Fox and MSNBC
do so well because all they do is spread bad
news, and we share it with everybody.
Good news, there's not GNN yet.
You know why there's no GNN in the world?
Good News Network?
Because no one cares about good news.
People care about bad news, right?
So why don't these guys change their name
from CNN to BNN - like Bad News Network instead
of CNN?
Okay.Hear them out.
Don't be defensive.
Hear them out what they have to say.
#7 is promise to improve.
Tell them, Listen, Hey, John, obviously I'm
not happy about the fact that we made this
mistake because as the leader, as the CEO,
as the executive, as the VP of this department,
as the whatever, this falls on me as the leader.
But I'm going to make one commitment to you.
We're going to get better at this.
And then offer a solution, Hey, would you
be open if . . . Would you be open if we did
this.
I'm sorry this is our mistake, but I want
to do you good.
Would you be open if we did.
. . Yes.
Great.
I don't want to pressure you, but would you
be open to this?
I would be.
Invite them to return for a second chance.
And then follow up on the experience.
And if you do that.
Listen, we're forgiving.
For most people that have valid complaints,
we're willing to get better.
We're willing to come back and give you a
second chance.
We like second chances.
But you've got to do your part and pay attention
to details because there's two different things
when it comes down to complaints.
I'll give you the short term problem and I'll
give you the long-term problem.
Here's the short-term problem.
Say I handle this solution and the customer
leaves happy.
But it was a valid issue.
If you don't go and fix that, you have a long-term
problem.
Yes, this customer goes happy.
My long-term problem is sitting down my staff
and saying, "Why do we keep making this same
old mistake?"
I don't mind new mistakes.
As the company grows, you're going to make
new mistakes which leads to new complaints,
right?
Like all of a sudden you come out with a department
that is doing this and some people are not
happy.
Well, this is a new mistake.
It's a new complaint.
We've got to figure out a protocol to make
this better.
But same old mistakes, same old complaints?
You know, if I go to a restaurant and the
complaint is always this place smells so bad
because the toilet is not cleaned very well,
there was a sushi spot I would go to.
It was amazing sushi, but the bathroom was
so bad that if you were within 4 tables of
it, I'm like, "Why don't you guys clean the
bathroom better and use a different detergent?
I can't stand this smell!
They didn't do anything about it over a year.
And I love this place, because they would
do a great job with sushi.
That smell alone got me to leave the place
and not come back.
So, pay attention to it.
It's extremely important.
It's by far your best critics, your customers
will give you so much feedback to improve
your company, increase the value of the company,
if you hear them out.
So, with that being said, Paul, we don't have
a pillow here.
Why don't you just throw me a pillow.
I'm in the mood for any kind of a pillow.
Let's see what pillow Paul's going to throw
us.
We're at a hotel room here in Caesars Palace.
It's crazy.
Let's see what this pillow looks like.
Okay.
Hey.
Should we write something on this pillow?
Should we do like graffiti?
And like be charged 80 bucks.
We don't have the marker to do it.
if I did, I would do it.
You know what.
Let me see if this pillow's a little bit - look
at this pillow.
Look at this pillow.
This is a very, very nice classy pillow from
Italy that only today if you call them right
now, 1-800-softpillow, we will sell this to
you for $99 and if you call in the next 10
minutes.
I'm not doing an infomercial with you.
Hey, if you haven't subbed to this channel,
click on the button here to subscribe to this
channel.
And if you're not part of notification squad,
you know who you are.
i love our notification squad.
You're the first to comment.
Click on the notification squad here and if
you haven't posted your video for the quarter
million contest we have, go post your video
for the quarter million contest to come.
Ten of you guys will fly in to come and spend
time with us for a day.
One of you guys I'll come to you.
Go watch the video.
Paul, how about we put a link on the bottom
for people to know it.
And if you've got any questions, comments,
thoughts, comment on the bottom.
Take care everybody, bye bye.